feminine and romantic like an old black
and white movie or bold and aggressive
roberto cavalli style is still
unmistakable after more than 40 years in
the business Cavalli has a passion for
artisanship rather than the more
industrial approach they want to keep
the right they perfectly magnesia just a
microplane I pray because around mrs.
Docherty in just a minute that every
company as afraid that who needs some
quantity of business so today I feel
they don't give the space to the young
desire to become important today he's
left with the friendship and the
endorsement of many international stars
but in the beginning there was just one
Italian Bieber who he can't forget I got
the phone call in my office and they
tell inform at mr. kowalick missed his
forties looking for you I think I know
that mrs. Bundy was also fellow when I
took the televisor her I recognized the
boys she knew exactly what she was my
first time what will become of the
company in 10 years time he says lies in
his children's hands the future cavalli
is with them the factory my company is
karate as they name of them it cavalli
that means it is our power
you